[Music]
all right so guys would you guys ever
consider adopting no yes yes yes I would
this side of the room absolutely not
and if it's one of your guys's kids mmm
Oh in that way like no and I'm like
looks like I gots to do what I got to do
all that stuff
you know what I really do feel that I
feel like I feel like my kid would never
grow up do you think you would regret it
would you be like in heaven and they're
like oh [ __ ] look what's going on a
tiger Tigers like 18 years oils dressing
the same with like goggles and capes and
[ __ ] together we'll have upside-down
goggles and [ __ ] if you gave Tiger - Joe
he'd be stunted at his current age me
and Ike I'll be looking like this
all day long okay so Justin had died
okay [ __ ] I don't know
yeah you said that um so as it it's oh
uh I don't know I just feel like with
what she try to do more work Casey right
drag Authority yes yeah no it's hard
it's really hard I don't want to adopt a
stranger's kid yeah me too that's why
I'll buy the children
I'll buy the children and have a deal
quietly touch lonely ladies and they can
deal with the kid my problem is they're
usually very poor and I don't like yes
babies are you kind of know all jokes
aside um I knew I wanted to have my own
kids but then if I never had my own kids
and I would be okay mmm but what about
all the children any love in the world
there's so many they're so so so so many
I'm not qualified if the government
didn't see me as such a threat what I
would do what do they see why would they
come on guys they know me but come on
come on oh Wescott yeah oh wait they
didn't see me as such a threat I think I
would create a center like what's that
movie the [ __ ] is neulander expanse
no the one on Netflix with [ __ ] the
numbers and the
the number changes they're like number
five Umbrella Academy umbrella at
calormene umbrella calorie I'd [ __ ]
have one like that dude we'll call it
like a roof Academy or some [ __ ] there
you go and you know magic nah they damn
well better learn so what part of the
Birla Academy just that there's a bunch
of kids yeah I wanna be like that old
guy that's weird huh old guy with a
bunch of kids that's not even here it is
weird I don't think he was always old he
probably started off young and then he
kept it for many years
whoa pretty old Rooney I want to do that
we started it I want to give the
children of the world a chance they
never had like what Angela Lee known
that loaded a lead gen Joe Lee
yes very good Dalila believe whatever
his name is he said he's not Elizabeth
he's not on a [ __ ] list Vlad Vlad
please please
something like that Brad Brad here we
have her name is Micah Stouffer girl
[ __ ] dude it really was [ __ ] you
getting flamed on right now she has a
huge ass family in my opinion Jesus she
started the whole stove for the TV
dinners yeah I don't think so
I don't think so different Stoffer
family oh I don't think she's a spell
Ferreras but this is the family Oh cute
she got in trouble if you look at all
the children there do you see one child
just kind of standing out a little boy
the asian boy right yeah that's the
video that I saw from her
oh the the hurt hurt her adoption story
with him hmm so this is going viral
right now Oh recently she just did opt
in no no three years ago this is two and
a half years ago the story now is that
she is rehoming and if she used this
word rehoming
you know why cuz she got tired cuz he's
autistic
yes oh [ __ ] yeah so I can't take care of
this autistic boy I got too much on my
plate
oh yeah yeah
or our own beds can I help you tell this
to go for it this is why people are mad
all right they think that this girl used
this inspirational story of I could
adopt this child with special dates cuz
he needs my love also share what he knew
he had she knows in her videos like the
crying video the video or she's like
telling the real story she's like oh I
they weren't very transparent about all
the needs that this child needs right
and so there's she's saying like we knew
that he had something going on and
you'll need extra care but then when
when they finally got him in their home
they realized there's a lot more to it
how much research did she do well he was
a huge had special needs that special
need the problem is like she had this
whole [ __ ] video and it was and
that's actually a big reason why people
started also following her cuz you've
even seen it right yeah I thought big
thing right so like it was she was
benefiting fate of feeding big time
because she's a family vloggers trying a
trial she has all these posts of you
could never pull us apart I love this
kid he's always with us forever
and she has all these like things that
she's saying and then we find out it's
too much I read I gave up to a different
house like a [ __ ] straight dog's ear
like a stray dog [ __ ] dog did it yeah
there we go and then um
was he with her since like birth pendant
I don't know that he was two years old
when he got to the store for family
now he's four yeah I think that's enough
to get an attachment absolutely
oh yeah from not being able to speak to
now being able to speak and then now is
when you're like your first five are the
most crucial man research specifically
say what needs like know so that the
thing that the thing is that she's
trying to keep the privacy for the for
the child so late she hasn't mentioned
like what home what kind of family he
went to or whatever and like they don't
know what kind of needs I sure she
didn't you know it's my own
Neves he has and they didn't explain why
I want the problems work specifically
either in their family as to why they
had to be home and but we're just taking
it as like well you guys basically it
didn't work out and and and instead of
being responsible for your like choices
because you actually benefited from this
whole story and all that you you know
did this and kind of like threw it away
like ass like a dog that you didn't want
anymore that's how the thing that people
are pissed about is they were silencing
people that were commenting she was
deleting blocking the way she handled it
was really bad yeah it makes it more
shady it makes it seem like yeah she's
trying to like hide it or minimize
what's really about them like a couple
like they made it about them it wasn't
really about the kid it was about how
they felt and they kept you know in
their like apology video they were like
yeah I'm you know so had like thank
thank you for all the kind words for
those of you guys are supporting us but
every knows it's like it just really
felt like it was about them it really
wasn't about like and I felt like they
needed to be a little more transparent
if they were gonna make this public like
that well and it assumed that everyone
was on their side was they're trying to
persuade everyone well yeah yeah yeah
damn I get it because I watching that
video when she first adopted him like
like you know they they preface it were
like they've been thinking about this a
long time they've been contemplating it
they did a lot of research and then they
found they found him that they wanted to
adopt and then like they were jumping
through like a lot of hoops just to get
to him and then when they finally got
him like you know she was crying she was
really happy about it and so you you had
that like huge emotional roller coaster
with them where she's like oh my god
thank goodness like he's a loving family
now and then just to hear this like yeah
I would probably be pretty angry too
because I'm like what the [ __ ] like you
took all this time to prep and like to
try to adopt this kid like you fought
hard to adopt this kid and all of a
sudden you're like letting him go but I
could also understand that like you know
yeah maybe it is a little out of like
their hand to take care of him you know
like this must be from broccoli every
night
I wasn't ready for this [ __ ] you only
know how to make sandwiches what the buy
[ __ ] soy sauce everyday got
[Music]
beautifully put Bart my take on it -
it's like she has such a big family she
has a beautiful family she's a newborn
she has a new boy she has her hands tied
both of them made me like you have you
what do I do forward they just got a
vlog for work yeah I mean they each have
their own personal channels and then
they have a family channel so they're
doing okay on the YouTube game and but
it's just like I just don't see why this
family need needed to adopt and I think
they they yeah there was cloud chasing
in my opinion I think so man that's what
people are pissed about is that they're
like well his videos are still up you're
still benefiting from like all of the
followers and everything that you've got
but people that specifically followed
for their journey a lot of them are
dropping like flies now - yeah where
their journey India even if it was for
cloud chasing I I did feel like it was
very genuine the video yeah really even
if it was completely adoption the
original original it is all very genuine
like I really wanted to give it a try -
Kevin oh good boy filmed it really well
it seemed legit the colour correction
correction the framing was be ridin see
this but one day adopted in yeah just a
small little clip of them crying this is
the first video in a second video this
is the last video this is the apology
video yeah and this is well let's judge
how they're crying where and see if it's
genuine
we're from we're from LA after multiple
assessments after multiple evaluations
numerous medical professionals have felt
that he needed a different thing as
medical needs he needed more wellhe's
medical meet well yeah what's ionization
so it's so vague yeah more baby food
literally what it is is I didn't know
that it took this much work for autistic
kid and I ain't got the [ __ ] time for
this [ __ ] exactly that's what it really
is yeah and I've been like even just
like the four other kids like how is
their relationship with this you know I
mean you guys have one kid and it's a
it's a handful ready cuz I'm just like
wow how do you guys even deal with that
and then there's four and a newborn I'm
like what the hell you're gonna do I
gotta say though wow I always get myself
look as a human being
like who knows social media people cuz
we're all we're all in that game
sometimes we all do things or sometimes
we all see different angles to things
where somebody's getting flame bombed
but then you know them personally and
you're like oh actually it's really not
as it's really not it's really more
complex than this yeah but it's more fun
when they're clearly strangers and
you're like [ __ ] these [ __ ] users
yeah they hate this baby they use this
baby I get it but man that's like
there's an angle to this where I can see
that it would be very hard to let go of
a kid like this and that they actually
are going through that seems very
difficult I don't know I mean I I think
that if I had to have a heart then my
opinion on it would for my imagination
on it would be hey let's do something
great yeah honey let's [ __ ] a dog
hell yeah there's so many kids that need
love in this world and they're just
impulsive about it and they're so
emotional about and they [ __ ] do it
and everyone's like hey watch out that
kid needs special me that I can handle
anything and then it actually ends up
happening and they're like oh [ __ ] dude
I can't handle this
yeah we'll throw a little love at it
that's all yeah it's an egotistic care
of Tourette's or anything I don't know
they don't really say all kids have
Tourette's do they have you been around
all kids they say some [ __ ] out of
nowhere and you're like well I capture
him being a nuisance if they're a family
channel and they're like rated G and
then he's just Yellin [ __ ]
you know the rest of the word just
saying the n-word every like five kids
while they try to like do like I don't
know [ __ ] post cereal brand deals
then it's like on this is this kids
bringing us down so like he learned the
n-word off camera guys from us
[Music]